the cop 25 meeting which is happening in  Madrid right now is almost over and we  unfortunately probably already know the  outcome world leaders are still trying  to run away from their responsibilities  but we have to make sure that they  cannot do that we will make sure they  that we put them against the wall and  that they will have to do their job and  to protect our futures I remember a few  months ago when I first saw the pictures  from the strike in Torino and when I saw  those pictures of countless of people  just filling up the streets  I felt so hopeful millions of people saw  those photographs and that gave hope to  millions of people so thank you to the  city of Torino  you